why can't we buy these tanks the army
says they'd only why can't we buy the
solar-powered abortion machine we got
twenty trillion reasons got twenty
trillion reasons we got twenty trillion
reasons about twenty trillion reason why
can't we build a border wall that
touches the sky stay on our mama's
health care until we're 45 we got twenty
trillion reasons got twenty trillion
reason we got twenty trillion reasons
about twenty trillion reason way juries
to reach their now up here we're clean
and dead is like this guy it should be
nowhere near the teeth and we got about
forty trillion reasons without today but
maybe if we just spend one more will
stay now twenty trillion dollars tacked
together might reach the Sun it could
even last Johnny Depp for over a month
your guy we got twenty trillion reason
it's got twenty trillion reason we've
got twenty trillion reason over twenty
trillion Reed we could pay off the tab
by buying unneeded Jeb or just identify
as being not that in dead or we still
have twenty trillion reasons still have
twenty trillion reefs still have twenty
trillion reason over twenty trillion
pay Social Security since I was first
hired will that program still exist on
the day I retire for God my car is
locked in the to our Park is Oh show me
the way I think I hear my third white
car big I got a part of Saul down left
on the comet ready baby let me just
spend one more I gonna pay
[Applause]
me who gonna play
a
[Music]